you know it was just really watching
that film Interstellar and seeing those
waves uh that you know you gotta spoil
because those are black hole waves dude
okay so we send you down there you can
surf this this like tidal wave uh uh for
a black hole near a black hole but your
time slows down and all the people
waiting for you up at the spaceship you
live 15 minutes and they live 20 years
nobody's waiting for your ass to Surf
that wave
[Music]
this is star talks sports edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I'm your host and I got
my co-host Chuck Nice Chuck baby what's
up Neil all right Chuck an actor
comedian and but more importantly my
co-host Gary O'Reilly thanks for thanks
the UK for creating you uh your former
Soccer Pro and and game announcer and we
got you for as my other co-host for this
so thanks for coming in and making this
happen now you put together this show so
tell me what you and a ticket crack team
of producers so what do you got for us
today yes we have a guest born in Hawaii
right a little hint of a clue there
given the name Kai which I do believe in
Hawaiian language is the sea wrote his
first wave aged four 20 something years
later he's a red ball athlete eight-time
stand-up paddle world champion if I'm
not mistaking the youngest ever
Surfer Hall of Fame inductee wow 2019.
in 2020 Chuck you'll love this he won
the toe-in surfing challenge at Nazareth
well you know you know that place well
you know it just doesn't get any bigger
than that
you see what I did there
yeah I mean these are these are liquid
Avalanches these aren't waves these are
monsters of the deep uh he's a
Windsurfer paddle boarder we know
Windsurfer kite Surfer Wing foiler he is
considered by those that know the
ultimate water man anything on the water
the man does it okay we're in the
surfing World little Jesus because he
rocks on water
well with 70 foot Liquid avalanches and
our guest is still alive
and just just to add another facet to
this rather incredible Diamond he's also
an environmental campaigner who does
a mat of plastic all right I know but he
gets he gets down there and he cleans up
himself so he's he's probably fantastic
so my having said all of that Kai Lenny
all yours Neil welcome
thank you dude for for coming on to
start talk oh thanks it's a pleasure to
be here with you guys and uh you know I
got so many questions for you guys no no
no no it's the wit no that's a different
show if you're gonna ask me questions we
got questions for you you're not every
day um we don't get somebody like you on
the show so what is this I hear that the
ocean is like a battery pack for you
what does that mean uh you know I think
just the ocean for me is like kind of
what keeps me going
um it definitely I think beyond having
you know my family and my kids it's kind
of my purpose I wake up every morning
and I just have this drive and longing
to get in the water and experiment and
uh you know ultimately ride the biggest
waves I can find but the ocean calls to
you it's a calling for sure
um and you know one of my favorite big
ways in the world is 15 minutes down the
road here on Maui and it's called uh you
know the world knows it by the name Jaws
but in Hawaiian it's called PE Ahi which
means the beacon or to be called because
it calls people from all around the
world and it called me since I was you
know a little kid I think one of my
earliest memories uh alive was being on
the cliff watching my heroes surf this
gigantic wave so you know what better
place to have been born to become a
product of my environment I am today
um than having Mount Everest is sort of
in your backyard speaking of little kids
what what's a safe age for a big wave I
mean you're a big wave surfer I mean
how's that does some you of course you
got to graduate today that but I'm
saying how young would it be or could
you be and somebody said get on out
there kid go ahead and get your first
big wave well you know I always thought
you know surfing is kind of like this
activity or water sports in general are
these activities that are kind of
outside of society's bubble I feel like
the rules change you know you could have
you know all the money in the world all
the opportunity in the world um but at
the same time
um you know there's a different pecking
order out in the water there's like a
different kind of like it's very tribal
I would say
um and I mean that in the most positive
way you know you kind of go back on our
ancestral Tendencies uh and when I first
served Jaws was with Laird Hamilton and
Dave colomo when I was 16 years old and
back then I thought that was like young
I was probably like the second youngest
person to ever go out to Surf these like
proper big waves
um because it's sort of like a Line in
the Sand where you could surf a giant
wave maybe on the outer reefs here
um that could be a 30-foot face but as
soon as you go to a place like Jaws or
payahi
um all of a sudden it's like a
completely different energy level I
would say there's like five or six big
waves I know around the world that have
sort of this next level energy that
um you know it's I don't know how you
could measure it but it's you can feel
it in the air you know how energy can't
be you know created or destroyed you
know it starts with the sun it goes to
the atmosphere the wind and it goes into
the ocean and then when these waves
explode this energy gets released and
you don't know what it transforms into
necessarily but it almost feels like it
goes into yourself
but nowadays kids are starting to serve
these giant waves at like 12 13 years
old and I'm like think to myself are
they even strong enough can their limbs
handle getting pulled out and it's
actually been quite remarkable and
eye-opening how how big a waves they can
not only ride because they got the skill
set but how they can survive and they
come up smiling and I'm like maybe this
generation's just built completely
different but wait so so you're you're
ready to sit on the porch and say these
young whippersnappers coming up yeah
I remember in my day at 30 years old
that's what I'm thinking I'm like I'm
like oh my gosh these guys are Next
Level I mean guys and girls you should
see these little kids that are you know
they're going to be leading the sport
into the future big way of riding um and
it's really exciting you know I think
part of you know being a big Wave Rider
of any kind is it's it's kind of like
you can come in really hot for a couple
of years and you could be amazing but to
be able to sustain you know the long
career through big waves is really
difficult just because you know it's
life and death sometimes it's yeah
um you know it doesn't happen every
single day so you don't have the
opportunity to necessarily practice you
kind of get flung in from a flat summer
into an apocalyptic winter and you know
while the rest of the world's you know
kind of bummed that it's gonna be like
an El Nino winter all the big wave
Surfers are rejoicing because that means
bigger waves and more consistent big
ways so you said you're 15 minutes from
a big from a big wave location so that
means if we were to imprison you
two people just put you in Colorado or
something that's a landlocked state and
you would you would you would die you
would I probably it would over I would
probably my life cycle would be much
shorter but I'd probably find a mountain
to Tomahawk down you know right okay it
just starts snowboarding right yeah
yeah
and I thought you know my biggest
inspiration for big waves was uh
snowboarding because it got to the point
where you know you can ride a big wave
you could go straight you can ride
inside these giant barrels
um but I wanted to what's the next level
and that's doing big Aerials on big
waves and if someone like Travis Rice
um one of the legends of snowboarding
can go to Alaska and do you know an
80-foot jump and do three rotations two
rotations
um why can't I do it on a big wave and I
actually ended up going to Alaska a
couple weeks ago
um and actually experiencing with him
what it's like and I'd have to say being
in the mountains to me is far scarier
than actually
um riding big waves big waves like oh
it's only a 50 to 60 80 70 foot wave on
the face or these mountains are 2 000
vertical feet and you have gases 500
foot Cliffs Avalanches coming behind you
that'll happen yeah yeah yeah it makes a
good movie scene where the Avalanche is
behind you you and can you ski faster
than the Avalanche
I experienced that
so we're in a position to throw some
Physics at what it is you do and do you
think much about the physics of of your
rotations and your speed and the waves
themselves yeah absolutely
um I you know I was never really good in
math at school I think I had so much
energy sitting down wasn't kind of my
calling
um and and looking at numbers but when I
really got into what I'm doing now today
um it's funny how
um the passion can bring out things that
I wasn't necessarily good at like the
physics of things try to understand all
the rotations and then even like trying
to predict these big waves you end up
sort of becoming a meteorologist trying
to read weather patterns and understand
all these sort of things and you know
the tides of the world and so on and so
forth but uh I'd love to hear what what
your thoughts are on all but I'll just
set up the stage here and then I know
Gary and Chuck have questions so in case
the public doesn't know a wave moving
through through the water is the speed
of energy that has been deposited in the
water at some earlier point so water is
actually not moving at that speed it is
the energy of all the water molecules
communicating the floor of that energy
from one molecule to the next
so that's why like you ever see a duck
sitting up on a you know in the ocean
and then a wave just comes under the
duct it just goes up and down the that
energy went under the duck and kept
going but the water didn't transfer
until you get to the Shoreline
where the energy has to go somewhere
where is it gonna go and if it's a
really deep ocean
a tiny little wave in the deep ocean
measure up how much that energy is and
as the shoreline gets shallower and
shallower
that energy is still there but it's not
moving as much water so it has to move
the water higher and you get bigger and
bigger waves as the shoreline gets
shallower and shower and now that it's
100 of everything I know about what you
do so yeah
well
he knows why when you have a shelf off
the uh Shoreline the waves get that much
bigger at that place because all at once
that all that energy is now slammed up
to the Shelf but now it boom has to go
somewhere so it goes up and over correct
it goes up right because it was carrying
that much more mass of water previously
and now in if the water if the the shore
is shallower then
the mass of water isn't available to it
so it's got to do something the energy
has to go somewhere and so it raises it
higher Against Gravity that's what it's
doing it has the power to do that so
caught when you when you get towed up
you're on one of these big waves do you
know in advance what trick you're about
to perform or do you have to make
intuitive on the spot locations yeah
that go you know what this wave this
angle this wind I need to bring this
trick or is there some of you
pre-planned how you're going to do this
because you've got to get the Artistry
influence your decision yeah yeah so
another way to say it is are you are
your is your performance bespoke to each
wave you know it's for there's no two
waves ever alike even at a perfect spot
um and a lot of these places I the
tricks or kind of the approach that I
have really depends on the spot I'm
traveling to
um you know for example here in Hawaii
because we have no continental shelf and
it just Rises the mountain rises from
super deep water I um I'll I'll kind of
find the right equipment to ride so like
let's say if I'm getting towed into a
wave my board will be 13 pounds here
um and I will be you know probably
traveling at around the wave itself will
be going 25 to 30 miles an hour
depending on the amount of jewels that
the storm produced so on the biggest
days we'll get 27 000 30 000 joules and
then the wave will be like a big day out
there is 20 feet at 20 seconds which is
kind of the small interval and the C
height that it travels from 4 000 miles
from the storm and
um you know I guess really and with
having all that knowledge and knowing
that there's like a 25 knot trade wind
um there's gonna be a chop going across
the phase I'll know that trick I want to
do at the beginning if I have the
opportunity is a backside 360 and I'll
be going left instead of right and when
I land my board will it'll be more of a
540 than a 360. so I'll be kind of
landing on right again and that'll put
me in the perfect position to drop in
and hopefully pull into the barrel of
these giant waves the tricky part about
big waves or just waves in general is
it's you can have a plan but if you
stick too much to it you're gonna kind
of like it's like dancing with a partner
um you're if you're kind of trying to do
your own thing and you're not kind of
adjusting to that person
um it's gonna look forced it's gonna not
look right it's not gonna be fluid so in
the back of your head I always have an
arsenal of Maneuvers or things I can do
and as it kind of comes without thinking
I just kind of like do you know it's
like you don't think about walking but
you know that you have to put the next
foot forward every time you step and
it's kind of like that so I spent a lot
of time doing visualization
um if I'm doing a long plane ride
somewhere you know I'm just praying it's
not my last plane ride and I'm also uh
thinking about how I'd want to do it so
having music is a trigger
um and trying to kind of place myself
there and get my heart pumping to the
point where I feel like my Palms are
sweating on an airplane I feel like I'm
there you're factoring so much in there
the wind speed the knowledge of a storm
far out at Sea how much energy is coming
towards you but surely the the the the
underwater terrain matters right the if
there's a slow change that'll have a big
effect on the wave won't it yeah and and
that's like uh it's a great Point
um every wave that I travel to I have a
really good understanding of the spot so
like here at Jaws peahi
um the bathymetry is really unique um
that's symmetry love it oh
look at that new word alerts
but the bathymetry of like just the
Contour So like
um for example we don't have a
continental shelf here in Hawaii it just
is deep water and that's the reason why
um all of the uh the waves here
um have so much force because you can
basically guarantee that same energy
coming from the storm is gonna just
unload and that's why Hawaii's known as
being one of the best big wave places on
planet Earth maybe one of the more
consistent ones
um here you know just to remind people
the Hawaiian Islands are volcanic cones
so they come up from the bottom of the
ocean so you're you're so
it's not the continental shelf it's just
the the the the the the Mountainside as
it enters the water right is that the
mountain continues all the way down and
so that's a beautiful Mass yes there it
is
and just because we've like the the
island itself is constantly kind of
breaking into the ocean I mean the big
island of Hawaii which is you know you
could fit all the other Islands into it
Maui was at one point with similar size
and you can just see daily that the clip
kind of is eroding away just from the
salt and it's almost like the volcanic
rock is resting because we have this Red
Dirt
um so there's a lot of Ledges along our
Coastline and that kind of will take all
that swell energy like you described
earlier and we'll Force the waves
vertically kind of ledge up but the
interesting thing is is you think with
all this Coastline that these giant
waves coming in would actually be
vertically taller everywhere
um but there's a lot of places there's a
lot of you know underwater conditions
that it requires like jaws has a giant
trench that travels way out to sea and
um it basically takes all that energy
and it kind of sandwiches it in and it
forces it in into this kind of like I
would say track and the track kind of
comes in and now there's this perfect
triangle of reef not really Reef
Boulders I we call them dinosaur eggs
because what I believe happened is there
was this big point this big Cliff that
had eroded away and what was left was
the Bedrock and over time it turned into
these Boulders because they kept rolling
and on a big Wipeout when you fall out
at Jaws um you can actually hear these
dinosaur eggs probably the size of an
entire living room going clink clink
clink and your worst nightmares between
one of us oh wow and you hear this big
sounds in the wave itself produces this
violent sound this percussion but
underwater you could hear Rock going
and you know you kind of bounce off
those rocks sometimes but luckily
they're pretty round from kind of
rolling around but then there's all this
to these fingers there and what gives
you these long long hold Downs at this
particular wave is that similar to this
if this is shallower and this is deeper
you can get stuck in these fingers and
the water is traveling faster above you
so imagine letting go of a balloon
inside and it floating and hitting the
ceiling the water is moving so much
faster above your head and you're kind
of in this spinning Vortex that you try
to come up and we have these inflation
vests so we're wearing these airbags
under our wetsuits with CO2 canisters up
to 35 milligrams and or grams and you
pull it
um it just blows your airbag up and you
brings you the surface like a cork but
when the water is moving too fast above
your head you can't penetrate yourself
you're bouncing off of the faster
Rushing Water yeah exactly and it's like
if you try to like dive into a river
you're gonna get swept across versus
kind of traveling across the river right
and so the hold Downs can vary from if
you're lucky five seconds underwater and
if you're unlucky you could be under for
well over a minute and you could be
dragged maybe three fields
that's
insane here's the deal though mentally
yeah all right the first time this
happens to you then you're okay used to
five seconds but now you're down for 30
seconds 35 seconds
what is what is the training that you
have to go through to say I'm not gonna
die or do you just go I'm gonna die
that's it and the first time I fell when
I was 16 I was like underwater I'm like
well I lived a good life I'm dead
and I opened my eyes and I saw like it
looked like the most violent scene I've
that you could ever paint it was just
these giant thunder cloud lightning
clouds moving at us at a speed that
looked like a time lapse it was just
going so quick and such deep blue water
and you just felt like the whole ocean
you're trapped under because in a second
you're 60 feet under water so you have
to clear your ears immediately otherwise
you'll blow your eardrums out
um and then it's like you feel the
pressure all of a sudden on your lungs
and you know the there's no training for
that you kind of have to have this is
where like you can do all your homework
you can do everything possible but you
sort of have to have faith in yourself
and I always believed that if you didn't
you know if you didn't believe in a
higher power put yourself in that
situation you start praying to someone
anyone
having described all of that is that why
you went into other other events like
paddle boarding I mean to be honest
um my heroes for me uh they did all
these things and I was heavily
influenced in this place on Maui is the
mecca of
um big wave surfing windsurfing uh and a
lot of these Sports have been invented
here um yeah and we know that ancient
Hawaiians used to paddle on surfboards
with canoe paddles so stand up paddling
but it was kind of rebirthed here by
these legendary figures um and then you
know a lot of things have been invented
um that have actually helped us kind of
realize the potential of the ocean
um like kite surfing was created here
and most recently the hydrofoils it's
been finally used now as personal use
um and now that's a real sport that is
kind of forced everyone to learn physics
uh or the understanding of fluid
dynamics uh yeah and it's just it's
really cool now because like when
there's there's big waves maybe five
times a year that are in the exceptional
range let's say 50 to 60 70 feet high
um half that we have to be able to be
entertained somehow some other way and
what better way of understanding big
waves that break along the shoreline
than the swells that are out in the
middle of the ocean and so in the
summertime I'll take my hydrofoil board
or my paddleboard or whatever and I'll
go right open ocean swells between the
islands come on with with the the wing
foiling how much
differences there between the physics
that you're presented with as a big wave
surfer and then this sort of inter
island
foiling that you do also like between
the um like using the wing and then
going like on the swells between islands
yeah so there that is like it's funny
because there's a as a surfer you're
um your perspective is not is right
where the wave breaks it's never beyond
that and so you know when you're able to
like utilize these other kind of
equipments or facets of
um equipment you basically have the
ability to see beyond just where the
wave breaks uh and with the wind you
know as a serper you've always watched
Birds ride the the the Ridgeline of
these swells and get all this energy
from the updraft of the uh of the Wind
on these swells and and it's just
beautiful with the wing that was kind of
always my dream is to ride along the
crest of the wave like I was a bird I
mean it's constant Chase for flight
um but the cool thing about like the
wing is you know you can be jumping and
flying like a bird on the way out and
then you could be riding the swells from
way out in the ocean in and then ride
the Breaking part of the wave and have
you know because you don't have surface
tension of the board dragging across the
water and you're kind of tapping into
that energy source like a fish Mite or a
dolphin you know below the surface
getting all this lift from the front
wing of this hydrofoil
um you know you basically are able to
kind of my perspective on doing sports
or if I have an idea for a sport is if I
had a kind of a spectrum of color and I
would look for the gray areas between
them and I'd be like okay I my the
premise of this is I'm looking for
something high performance in all
conditions and if I can find something
super high performance
you know and and eventually I figure out
that this one particular area I'm not
doing something high performance what
could I create so that I could be doing
something fast exciting basically trying
to give me the adrenaline fix a big wave
might give me
um and so you know that leads you to
what's scarier than
testing your skill by basically foiling
a cross between open ocean islands and
shark infested you know that's the
trigger yeah sure enough basically going
and surfing these swells and it's like
playing a kind of a game of chess with
the ocean because the swells are popping
up it's all local windswell it's not
this long Groundswell that is perfectly
farmed for a long time it's this sort of
like game of Ivory 100 yards maybe last
you know even 20 yards a wave is doing
this and you're kind of hopping from one
to the next and if you get in a rhythm
with the ocean it's sort of like being
on a swing or pendulum and it just kind
of takes you oh it's interesting
what do you do in the bathtub
I mean it's like I'm probably using my
hand to create a wave
all right so speaking of that's uh
barrels and technique so I just love
watching surfing like it's so poetic you
know and I've noticed when you guys do
tricks and maybe I'm noticing wrong
you'll let me know it looks as though
like a skateboarder you actually use the
wave like the face of the wave you kind
of surf down it to pick up speed but
then you surf back up it to do the trick
but then somehow you find because the
whole wave is continually curling it
doesn't care that you're there but then
somehow you find like the lip you do
your trick but then you come right back
down in the place where it is once again
curling like over you and you're you
what is going on man like that is I mean
it's really crazy it's just insane
wouldn't is I mean am I right when I'm
seeing this is that what I'm seeing oh
absolutely you're spot on um you didn't
like skateboarding the only difference
is is that that ramp is ever changing
and so your decision making of when
you're gonna hit that lip to catch air
or to do a big turn it all happens maybe
a millisecond before you get there so
you kind of initiate your bottom turn if
you go too far into the flats you're
going to lose a lot of speed but you
might want to do that in order to set up
for a barrel but if you're trying to do
an aerial you would cut across mid face
and you'd actually really load your Fins
Up so there'd be a lot of like pressure
you'd pressure them so they'd be kind of
pre-loaded and as you're coming up
without forcing and trying to pull the
board with you you kind of allow the
wave to push the board into the bottom
of your feet so the wave is kind of
spitting you out absolutely the way it
is like a dance you know
um The Wave is in itself you have to be
if you're so in tune and timed with the
wave you can it basically is the one
that's kind of helping you along like
it's it's your dance partner it just it
kind of gives you that that ability you
know people always wonder how do you
keep your board stuck to the bottom of
your feet and sometimes it's you
utilizing wind that's going into the
wave and that kind of is like a glue to
the bottom of your feet but most of the
time it's hitting the lip at the right
trajectory at the right speed because
speed is your friend and the board kind
of or the board Lee starts leaving the
water and the lip sort of TAPS the
bottom of it and it forces it into your
feet and your momentum moving forward
kind of grips into it and as you rotate
it just comes down to where your eyes
are drawn to where you're looking where
your hand position is so keeping your
back hand lower than your right hand
keeping your left hand high so you kind
of pendulum around or kind of you know
pirouette rather so it's like a bunch of
little things and you can definitely
drive yourself into Insanity trying to
figure it out because you go and try to
put this to practice and unless the wave
is a good enough wave or gives you the
opportunity you know in a single session
you might only get one or two tries
um you know unless you're at somewhere
really perfect or if you go to the
latest man-made waves of the world which
you know are in Waco Texas
um and you know uh didn't we have Kelly
Slater one doesn't he have one yeah
exactly yeah yeah and it's the dream to
be able to go someplace and practice a
maneuver
repeatedly and not be like waiting for
the ocean to spit something out and also
because that's the thing with surfing
it's not like okay it's your turn to go
down the ramp it's literally like
surfing's tribal enough where you know
I'd say 60 to 70 percent of the time
you're battling with other people to be
positioned in the right spot to go down
the wave and you might have the best
section of the entire day but there
could be somebody paddling out and in
your way and drawing your eye or just
being in simply in your way to hit it so
you're like
I think that's why Surfers can get quite
frustrated because it's this finite
resource that doesn't happen all the
time and everyone is like kind of
battling over it well it kind of that's
what I always that's what I always
wondered I when I first saw surfing as a
city kid it was featured on ABC's Wide
World of Sports yeah and and there
they're all the Surfers just waiting out
there beyond the cresting of the weight
and they're just waiting for a wave to
come and I just thought
suppose you get like a crappy wave
suppose call yourself
it's sometimes you know because there's
like usually the best waves of this like
a set of waves that come in most time
there's three waves in a set
um at certain spots there could be up to
ten waves in a set which is the dream
but three waves in a set first wave
usually cleans the line up so you don't
usually go the first wave and then the
second wave is usually the best wave
because there's not a the water has been
taken off the reef
um or the sand Bank
um and there's like it's shallower so
the way it's gonna stand vertically
better and might Barrel
um and then there's always the risk that
the third one's gonna be the biggest
wave but at the same time it could come
in smaller it's kind of that wild card
one where you could you know do
everything right get the second wave of
the set be like I got the sickest wave
and you could kick out and the third one
was the better one but then it's a risk
it's 50 50. a lot of times you could be
like okay it's my turn everyone knows it
I'm going to let the second wave go and
then the Third Way is going to kindness
give me the want and it's flat it just
didn't come in it was only a two wave
set you're like ocean hates me
if you're not in rhythm with the ocean
that is like that is that is just your
worst sessions come when you're not in
tune with the ocean and the best Surfers
that have won the most championships are
the Kelly Slaters of our sport
um essentially you know he has the
ability he almost looks like people
think from the land that he's willing
the ocean bending the ocean to as well
you know he's like he can paddle over
here into her what is he doing wave
hasn't broken there all day and then all
of a sudden he'll get the 10-point ride
and he'll win the World Championship
that has happened to him you know he's
11 World titles it probably has happened
to him seven of those World titles and
that's how he he is one with the ocean
one with the ocean and you know I think
his trick is he's been doing it so long
and he's so so knowledgeable he could
read because the ocean always gives you
kind of triggers a little signs like
before a big swallow appears yeah cues
like the watercolor starts to change
here from this kind of aqua blue to his
turquoise and you're like really down to
fine detail really big details and then
you start the wind sometimes even shifts
when a big swell comes in it'll hear
instead of the normal North East Street
we do have to have all of your senses on
high alert don't you exactly because
it'll turn like the wind might turn a
little more easterly and it's just
because of the disturbance of that storm
and the storm usually gets drawn or it
follows the um swells pretty far so it's
changing kind of the wind patterns
around us
um so it's all these little cues and
it's even like
um that we have all as a surfer you're
always looking for indicator waves so
you look down the coastline and you look
for waves that might pop up and give you
kind of a hint like oh okay a set is
coming or oh a Westerly directions like
a swell at 225 is going to come in or
this set is 235 degrees you know you're
kind of like you're taking in little
cues and Kelly's so good at that he
knows that tithe he even knows like the
time a swole will hit and because we
have such a vast array of buoys in the
Pacific you can actually time when the
the biggest wave is going to come in you
could be like okay at 1 15 the set of
the day is going to come in because
that's when the buoy reading was highest
and that's when there was like the most
consistency yeah but I thought you guys
are just out there twiddling your thumbs
waiting for me look at this I mean yeah
some people are so in tune they don't
even know that they're doing this right
right they became instinctive so let me
so you you know enough based on this
conversation at least that
I I've learned that you make your own
equipment is that because you know more
than the people who made the commercial
equipment and so you have to improve
upon it is that what's going on I have
the ability and the advantage that I'm
able to ride conditions that most people
can't
um and I can I have the feedback in my
head and I usually try to translate that
feedback to the master Shapers that I've
worked with or the designers of you know
my sales my kites my wings and then the
hydrofoils and all that and I've gone to
entry trying to translate this trying to
translate a color to somebody who's
never seen color before you know it's
like this it's always on the tip of your
tongue it's like Indescribable and so
you know I'm always going to the factory
uh or like kind of our Factory is an old
pineapple Mill here in the the jungle of
Maui
um with ironically some of the highest
technology of the surfing industry you
know all arrows space
basically stuff that kind of trickles
down to you know us normal people we we
take and we try to like use it to make
our equipment better
um and so yeah like a lot of my best
ideas for how I'm gonna ride waves um
and win has come from just epiphanies
out in the water where it's like how did
I not see this it almost took me 15
years of trying to work up the latter
one particular Sport and then all of a
sudden you know you see the light and it
just comes so clear and you're like I
have to go in immediately and write this
down or I have to go straight to the
people that I work with to try to
translate this and
um I'd say have the ability to actually
do it all myself but it's really nice
working with people who are so focused
on this one sort of skill set to make
either the boards the hydrofoils or the
Kites and you know it's it's pretty cool
so the board the boards are water
resistant is that correct well the board
usually the boards are um foam core so
for the longest time it's been
polyurethane cores
um and then it's it's really
transitioned a lot I would say 50 into
EPS
um core
um and you know now everyone's starting
to kind of lean towards kind of um uh
environmentally friendly foam that's
made out of CLG made out of sort of
different stuff that if it was to be
outside it's fiberglass or carbon fiber
shell because it really like it's the
boards are like a basically a crab soft
on the inside and hard on the outside
um but then you don't want too stiff of
aboard too strong of a board you want
Flex in it so the art form is taking the
fibers and basically being able to layer
the board in such a way that the board's
gonna like dampen and bend and absorb
the C chop or the water and and and give
you sort of like suspension so it's more
like a more like a read the way reads
are designed they blow with the wind
they Bend they don't break yeah exactly
and if you're here in Hawaii and you
watch the you know a palm tree a 70 80
foot palm tree right like looking at
tree Sway in the wind they're so strong
but they have give to them and they kind
of absorb so it's like finding that fine
line of not too much cab to the point
where it's gonna break but then you know
stiff enough that you can have like you
know you can translate your body
mechanics and energy into that board and
then into the water are there any
natural water repellent solutions for
your equipment as opposed to the
high-tech stuff that you you we hear and
see a lot about well so back in the old
days you know you would uh the Hawaiians
would cut down a poetry they'd carved
the board from within the coach and in
order to seal it they would use some
sort of oils um I know nowadays we use a
lot of linseed oil to kind of seal wood
and so
um I don't know the exact uh oil that
they would use but it's basically they'd
rub the oil across across the the wood
and it would just seal it just enough so
water would kind of absorb it it would
repel as well
um and and so that was like kind of the
natural way of sort of doing that and
that's kind of like the the core of
Surfing is first body surfing and then
second would be riding one of these kind
of traditional boards because it really
connects you directly to it and there's
both sides of the spectrum you know
there's no better feeling than riding
the kind of one of the you know Elias
it's called which is kind of a shorter
wood board that's really thin maybe an
inch and a half thick but then there's
the other side of Spectrum which is
pushing the high performance side of
everything and it's like what could we
take that you know modern science is
created and apply it to this and how far
can we go and so basically every
um top performing Surfer guess what
they're watching every space shuttle
launch because they're so into the stuff
that is created to make these Rockets go
to space and help us survive in space
everyone's just waiting for anything new
that was created to trickle down to us
so that we could like use it and maybe
it'll be that Silver Bullet to allow us
to ride the wave better or the wind
better
dude you could shoot my surfboard into
space and it can re-enter without
burning up that's right
so Kai we know you are environmentally
friendly and you will do your own Beach
cleanup along with a lot of other people
how do you balance that kind of removal
of plastic out of the ocean
and with all the high-tech stuff
equipments and sealants that can come on
a board or other surfing equipment how
do you how do you kind of keep that out
of the equation
yeah it's really ironic you know that
you want to keep the ocean clean and
pristine and yet we're riding boards
that are made of this kind of toxic foam
that you know won't dissolve in the
ocean for a thousand years
um or just you know plastic in general
everything you get shipped nowadays is
full of plastic
um you know it's wrapped in it it's uh
and and you know I noticed kind of when
we had the or when the tsunami in 2011
hit Japan
um you know at the time I was still in
my teens and Mr Fukushima
disaster that was that was a real
eye-opener
um because obviously you know since
growing up on an island you're really
impacted by sort of everything because
it doesn't get hidden it's like you go
to the beach and you're gonna see trash
or even if there's trash on the street
here there's nowhere to go you're on an
island in the middle of the Pacific and
you know the great gyre in the Pacific
turn into the okay garbage patch and
after that giant tsunami all that trash
or all the stuff that came from Japan
got stuck in the gyre so even today I'm
finding stuff along the beach that is
you know has Japanese emblems on um
Japanese writing and and you're like
this has been out in the ocean that long
you know and it's not even broken down
um the most common thing color you're
gonna see at plastic in the ocean is
white and blue because the red the the
brighter colors um tend to be eaten by
fish or chipped away as the sun sort of
hits it it kind of breaks down enough
into small microplastics fish will
absorb that and eat it and you know I've
had a lot of friends who've gotten
severe mercury poisoning in places they
shouldn't have gotten it and a lot of
people are kind of equating into the
fact that the fish are eating
um a lot of these Plastics and you know
generations of these fish are kind of
like metabolizing it and it's turning
into sort of a cancerous thing
um you know uh
basically when we do these giant Beach
cleanups it's like if you had a teaspoon
and you're trying to like empty your
bathtub while the faucet's on it's like
it looks good it feels good you know
you're doing your part locally you know
the turtles aren't going to get caught
in it and stuff and you know fish
hopefully aren't gonna keep eating it
but that's like the last place it ends
up and so trying to figure out how to
turn off the faucet you know it's always
like I feel like when you're trying to
preach to somebody or you're trying to
kind of like tell somebody what they
can't do and what they should do it's
like people want to rebel from that like
I don't want to be like told what I'm
doing you know I want to have that sort
of freedom and one of the solutions that
we've sort of come up with is
um you know at least uh endemically but
eventually hopefully mainstream is be
without necessarily changing the way
people live changing the products that
they're using and sort of not having
them realize that it's changed so um
been working with this company
um Atlantic packaging that's located on
the east coast is the single uh largest
um you know family American owned
packaging company and I mean they wrap
everything in plastic but they have this
initiative right now that we're working
on called A New Earth Project and it's
really cool because they're trying to
make packaging that is um out of
sustainable things
um so basically cardboards papers
um mushroom fungi uh trying to use
something like that to make it just as
affordable as plastic so that people
will you know companies aren't going to
lose millions and millions of dollars
billions maybe unpackaging alone to try
to ship their products and you'll give
them things up because everyone wants to
do the right thing but shareholders
bottom lines you know you kind of got to
play the game and so our all the boards
that I'm getting now that are shipped
around the world are you know wrapped in
packaging that is sustainable
um and you know literally if it ended up
in the ocean like a turtle could live
live off of the mushroom package that I
had yeah that's that's very cool that is
the key the key is to make it so that
um you're not asking people to change
their behavior you change the products
that are already a part of their
behavior so electric cars do that we're
we're still driving the same car and
everything like it's just that you're
plugging it into the wall there is some
carbon footprint there yeah but you're
not stuck the only thing you're changing
is you're not stopping at a gas station
to put gas in your car you know so you
you're not really asking people to do
something that different the the changes
in the is in the wall outlet so so Kai
um I don't know if you know but the New
York Aquarium just fished out of the
ocean its very first plastic fish that
it evolved as a plastic I'm just kidding
I wouldn't have doubted it for a second
because every time
my brother and I will go fishing off of
our wing foil boards so we'll have kind
of a hand line off of our harness and
we'll go out and we know where kind of
the holes are for I guess what people
know is like GTS or in Hawaii they're
aloha's
um they're these really like you know
they're they're kind of scarier fishes
than sharks ironically there's bullets
underwater but if you do bring them out
a lot of times if you look in the
stomach there's plastic in it and I'm
like if it's breaking down you know it's
going into their cells
well everything is you know they say you
are what you eat but everything is what
it eats I mean I don't know that nature
we'll be able to figure out a way to
just eat plastic and it'll be coming
soon and it'll be like metabolized and
it'll be like perfectly fine for
everything else because where nature
always finds a way we just might be
destroyed before then we'll all be long
exactly
so Kai just to land This Plane um do you
have any questions for me
Neil I have a lot of questions but I'm
going to keep it down to a couple I'm
looking for biggest surfable wave on a
planet ideally in our uh solar system
but if it's at least within the local
Galaxy I need I need basically light
speed soon so we can go through other
planets and okay so okay so here's the
thing
Earth
is the only object in our entire solar
system that has surface water
and you're surfing
water so the moon Titan of Saturn has
oceans of liquid methane so this is
liquid but not the right liquid
[Laughter]
there are several clues that have water
oceans beneath a frozen surface
and so
so and it does get title uh stressing to
it but the surfaces are all completely
frozen over and you get some ice geysers
that where the water punches through
freezes on the way out and then you get
these sort of ice geyser ice volcanoes
but Enceladus right right exactly but
right now Earth is the best you got
that's all yeah I figured in our solar
system you know it was just really
watching that film Interstellar and
seeing those waves uh that you know you
guys spoil because those are black hole
waves dude okay so we send you down
there you can surf this this like tidal
wave uh uh for a black hole near a black
hole but your time slows down and all
the people waiting for you up at the
spaceship you live 15 minutes and they
live 20 years nobody's waiting for your
ass to Surf that wave totally no totally
I mean that I was like that is the most
surfable wave I've ever seen I don't
know how that one of the characters died
because I'm like it's easy you just
would ride it and as you get to the top
I can understand he probably got flicked
a thousand extra feet above that thing
you know with all that land at the top
but last time you gotta duck through it
and then you'll just pop out the other
side it's easy because your name is Kai
Lenny that's why it's easy
who's talking here yeah but you know
another thing too is like we're
constantly trying to find other big
waves around the world because like
there can't only be five of these
gigantic places you know where
everything sort of lines up I don't tend
to believe that for example Nazareth is
in Europe it's in Portugal like it's in
sort of the backyard of Western
civilization and it was only surfed 13
years ago like when it was big like
people sort of discovered it and you're
like this place this mythical place was
kind of like if it's been around for as
long as humans have ever known but
before there at Nazareth was considered
you know a death sentence and not a
place that you would go ride a wave
um but that has me always thinking like
I'm on constantly on Google Earth trying
to find places to surf but if the image
of you know you can't see below the
surface right from the the on the Google
Images
um not on Google but you have we have
the means of doing that though but yeah
yeah so it's like trying to obviously if
you could see the right position the
path imagery and stuff like I guess on
Google Earth unless a photo is taken of
a place with a wave you kind of don't
understand a wave could actually be
breaking it sounds like what you really
want to do
is ask yourself and we do this in
physics all the time given everything
that given all these parameters that are
creating this effect yeah how do I
increase that effect all right what do I
have to change about the wind the
direction the water the the elevation
the all of this so what would be really
cool is if you you folk just ask
yourselves how do I maximize a wave on
this Earth
then get a whole bunch of money together
and create
the surfing environment with the uh and
have a wave generating thing that's out
there or have ways folk find some way to
maximize it you get 100 foot wave
that's what we want the mythical 100
foot wave
that's the dream and I don't see why you
can't just
put in the equations what will maximize
it building and then build it just build
it that way for nature to come together
with weird configurations do it Kelly
Slater's wave pool is probably the
tallest man-made wave um that it's like
surfable and we talked about that in one
of our episodes didn't we yeah we did
yeah we did yeah and that that whole
project was like I think somewhere 60 to
70 million and they got away that was I
mean they were inventing sort of the
technology now that it's a little more
established I've been the one I'm like
in Kelly's ear I'm in all those people's
years constantly I'm like you guys we
need at least a 30-foot face wave
because if you had that you would like
that way I've changed the landscape of
Surfing if you had a 30-foot wave we
would completely reinvent how we ride a
big wave because now all of a sudden you
have something to train on yes
completely not waiting random for random
nature to give you something it might be
good but this is exactly about
manipulating how to create bigger waves
um in the ocean uh you know not geostorm
engineering or anything like that don't
worry
the last I mean the last thing I really
would talk about is that is that
this swell height so
um the biggest swell I think ever
recorded was by Ireland um and it was
like a 70 or 80 foot tall swell and
um that was like a big deal and I to me
I was thinking I could ride that on a
hydrofoil you know that's probably I
mean to get out there is kind of the
hard part because there's probably like
you know millions of breaking giant
swells you know that it's a constant
chaos but you totally could ride one of
those on a foil and probably be less
dangerous than going to say a place like
Nazareth but there's this guy that um I
got leaked up with who created a drone
and he was um ocean scientist um
oceanographer and he created a drone
that sends a signal and bounces off the
water and he went to I'll have to send
you the link to one of his videos it's
funny because sometimes you know like
social media and all that there could be
videos that are so big in in like a me
like people get so many views and then
there's these other videos they get like
400 views and it is of something that's
so mind-blowing to me at least you know
he made this drone went to Nazareth and
he was bouncing a signal off of the
water to see the swelling because
Nazareth I would say out of all the big
waves in the world is the most unique
that I've been to in that there's a 10
000 foot trench that goes all the way to
the sand on one side and then there is
basically on the other side the Sand
Point you know this ancient kind of
Lighthouse is sitting on top of and uh
it's it's like the swell energy is going
the opposite direction it gets stuck in
the trench and it wraps back in and one
side of the beach so Pride de Norte is
where the wave breaks and the south side
of that beach it could be like a ripple
I'm not even joking a ripple and on the
other side it could be 80 foot ways and
you're like it doesn't make sense but it
does because this you know it's 10 000
feet of water there and then you know 50
feet of water over here but so he flew
the Drone out over and he wasn't even
trying to poor to people riding weights
he just wanted to test his drone and he
was bouncing the signal off the water
and the waves we don't go for and we
miss
um were he was recording 70 feet of
vertical height off of these swells and
he has it mapped down to like I think
it's down to like
a millimeter of accuracy with his drone
and
um and and I think the reason why it's
possible for a place like that to get
that bigger waves is it's this wedge
effect
um you know you have the trenches this
is important data if you're going to try
to do this perfectly right I mean yeah
so it's like the wave is coming in in
the trench the main predominant swell
and then the biggest way is at nazaree
don't break the farthest out they
actually break the closest in so what
happens is you you're always looking for
a wave where there's one wave coming
this way and it's basically a roadway
another wave comes out of the North and
then it hits and it doubles up so all
that energy has to go somewhere creates
this rise
so I already think people have written
100 foot waves maybe bigger 120 points
because the waves he was recording it
was not even a big day out there and I'm
like people have had to rid in taller
waves but we have yet to see hopefully
this winter I keep convince him to fly
his drone when it's really big over one
of the Waves I ride well if the weather
if the weather events get more dramatic
you'll be getting bigger waves indeed
indeed hey Neil what were the biggest
waves in all of time in the solar system
well you wanted to be around when the
moon formed
the moon so Earth was sitting there
minding its own business in space
orbiting the Earth and a mars-sized
protoplanet wayward
wandered into the Earth
sideswiped us excuse me bro
that's what it said
excuse me
sideswiped us
cast about one percent of Earth's crust
into orbit around the Earth so for a
while there Earth had a ring okay
and that ring rapidly coalesced
because if you're a big piece you have
slightly more gravity than another piece
and so it'll win in the who wins the
gravity and who attracts other small
pieces contest and that a creating of
material became Earth's moon
now
all evidence all theories of this
formation say that the moon formed 20
times closer to Earth than it is right
now
oh oh tidal forces go as the cube of a
distance
okay
so Chuck do you have a calculator uh I
can get one take 20.
take 20. you got one yep multiply it by
20. okay that's easy that would be 20
squared that gets you what 400. now
multiply by 20 again
what do you get eight thousand eight
thousand when the moon formed it raised
tides on Earth there were eight thousand
times higher than today that's I can't
even imagine it must have been chaos
around here 8
000 Times Higher
so it sounds like you and your peeps
want to go if you had
we need the Death Star
a little wave star
yeah it might be the death star for
everyone that is by the way the strength
of Tides is very sensitive to the
distance to the Moon
distance is a very sensitive
um indicator of the tides when we invent
time machines that's where you want to
go okay
I I kind of wonder if I've already been
oh
he's he's reincarnated no I wonder if
I've already been because my future self
made the time machine and I've already
gone back in time oh right you know what
that reminds me of during the science
March back in what 2020 no
2017. it's during the science March on
Washington but someone had a sign says
what do we want a time machine when do
we want it it doesn't matter
it's true it doesn't matter any time
would be good anytime works for a time
machine yeah yeah I mean another wave
that I mean talk about meeting the
environment in a big wave is um this one
time I was down in Patagonia with these
two Navy Seals on a Red Bull trip and we
were mountaineering and we were climbing
two mountains that had never been
climbed before ironically one was named
Shark Fin
um because it looked like a giant shark
fin but we were walking and I felt like
I was Frodo in The Fellowship of the
Ring it was just like this most Crazy
Train triple my entire life it was a
defining moment in 2013 and I was
walking across we were walking across
this kind of mountain and there was this
like glacial lake at the bottom and
there was this massive Glacier it's
probably since receded I don't know a
mile but I was standing there and and
and or we were walking and I looked down
and all of a sudden I saw a piece of his
ice fall into the water oh it displaced
all this water and all of a sudden this
perfect wave on this little like I think
it was like a sediment deposit
underwater it like it it was like a
mound a sea mount you know like there's
waves like Cortez bank that break off
California it's like a seamount makes
giant waves this wave broke and it was
the most perfect wave ever glassy
there's no currents it was just
plus when the when the glacier calves
like that it looks like it's almost in
slow motion yeah and so you're not even
thinking that there's much energy there
until you watch it manifest as a wave
and you say I better get my ass out of
there if you had some kind of rowboat
the cool thing about that whole
experience was I was predicting that
wave was 15 feet high and I thought
maybe because in comparison to the side
of the glacial wall I'm like that's a
50-foot wall I asked our guide that was
from Patagonia down there I'm like how
big is that uh glacial wall because we
were going to go into uh ice climbing it
later that day like on the safer side
and he's like that's 250 feet yep and I
was like okay so that wave buy my rogue
calculation was around 50 feet tall
right yeah wow and it was a perfect way
probably the most perfect waves I've
ever seen in my life it barreled down to
about like an inch it just kept bearing
the water is 32 degrees just to remind
just just to be clear okay yeah good
wetsuits no Hawaii 70 degrees 55 degree
no I get the wind chill here in Hawaii
with Hawaii windshield I feel so sorry
for you spoiler No One's Gonna Give You
any sympathy
yeah I don't need any good that's that's
the good I don't need it I don't need
that guys
Lenny thanks for being on Star Talk Neil
deGrasse Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
foreign
[Music]